the future of the world Santorelli it's
it said has been discussed in different
forums at the Royal Swedish Academy of
Sciences but also by young Academy of
Sweden I think it's a unique opportunity
for Sweden to actually provide or open
even more you know Sweden
internationally and also provide a I
would say in an interactive environment
for people at you know of all ages to
learn more about the science why science
is important why research is important
how should we educate you know the
future generations not only into what
can be done by being trained you know in
different areas but also what were the
implications of the things that have
been done long ago how these have
different inventions for example have
affected the Society of today and that's
exactly I think that the Nobel Center
should do that was something about the
history but also look into the future
and say these are the challenges
societal change challenges we need to
address and how can we use both the
historical inventions but also make sure
everything we do now and in the future
goes in the right direction